we hired somebody to help us with the
business that was just I should have you
know even when you say you should listen
to your instincts and we were feeling
like we were I don't want say
overwhelmed but we know we needed some a
consultant for something and we knew we
needed a consultant we weren't really
sure how to address it and somebody had
recommended somebody and we both felt
mmm you know there was something off and
then it turned out to be very very off
and I look at it that it was a learning
experience and it could have been a lot
worse and you know we caught it at the
beginning and now it's almost done but
it's the newest mistake I don't and I
think he is the worst mistake I guess
maybe because he was toxic I mean that
was the worst it was just someone who
lied and cheated and you know and it
happened I mean it's you know human
nature we've made a lot of mistakes but
nothing like big or bad yeah I mean we
usually catch them at a certain I mean
the good news is when you're relatively
small all yours to make mistakes are
relatively small as well and when you're
big they can be colossal and so as a
young very supple company we can recover
from but everyone makes mistakes I think
the real question is do you make the
same mistake twice
I think it's your gut is important i
think we probably should have done dude
more due diligence I think it was just
we were the business was moving very
very fast and frantically we know we
needed somebody and we were like alright
let's just do it well we've made we've
made higher we've had hires that have
been sort of got responses which have
been great and others that have not and
we've had other hires that weren't
necessarily got response but they were
hired nonetheless and again terrific
ones you know I think we necessarily you
know the lesson is or you know after 2-3
weeks what you have and we probably
should have reacted more quickly than we
actually did for a company of our size
the thing that i think is most crucial
in terms of what we do is hiring
somebody that culturally is a good fit
and if they're smart and they fill the
position in a manner for which they have
experience or we feel is appropriate
exciter etc having the cultural fit and
the passion for the business is probably
the biggest hurdle because we're only 20
people of which gene of 10 of those are
working sort of right out of our office
in New York City and I think that's the
most crucial aspect of where we are for
this size today